moment moment moment bakterien als
kraftwerke der ganzen menschheit das
tatsächlich eines der großen ziele der
sogenannten elektro mikrobiologie ein
komplett neues und innovatives
forschungsfeld richtig gehört denn es
gibt nicht nur bakterien die sich von
strom ernähren sondern auch welche die
rohstoffe in elektrizität umwandeln bot
ein video in zusammenarbeit mit der
redaktion von technology review eine
super zeitschrift und am ende gibt es
ein gratis exemplar für euch stay tuned
also bis zum ende klicks und science
fiction herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
ja das ist alles ein erbe aus der
frühzeit der erde und diese
mikroorganismen könnten damit nicht
weniger als eines der zentralen probleme
der energiewende lösen und uns damit
tatsächlich in eine neue derzeit noch
unvorstellbare energetische zukunft
führen einige bakterien sind nämlich
wahre allrounder in sachen strom
stäbchenförmige einzeller erzeugen
beispielsweise bei ihrem stoffwechsel
vergleichbar mit uns menschen und dem
kohlendioxid das wir ausatmen andere
markieren fressen den strom quasi und
produzieren daraus energiereiche und
wertvolle moleküle doch wie genau kann
man sich das vorstellen
vereinfacht gesagt sorgt die wanderung
von elektronen überhaupt erst für leben
denn im inneren aller lebenden zellen
wird dadurch energie erzeugt sie wird
frei wenn ein elektron quasi von einem
molekül zum nächsten elektro affinen
molekülen überspringt im zellinneren von
tieren und pflanzen beispielsweise
werden elektronen aus zuckermolekülen
benutzt um energie zu gewinnen werden
diese an sauerstoff weitergegeben und
zwar über eine elektronen transportkette
doch das ist nicht alles denn erst vor
kurzer zeit haben forschungsteams
folgende überaus überraschende
erkenntnis gewonnen
bestimmte bakterien können diese
elektronen sogar mit ihrer umgebung
austauschen und genau diese organismen
sind von großem interesse für das neue
forschungsfeld der sogenannten elektro
mikrobiologie hier versuchen
forschungsteams weltweit weitere
spannende erkenntnisse über diese strom
l'heure zu gewinnen welches molekulare
rüstzeug verleiht den bakterien diese
außergewöhnliche fähigkeit und wie kann
diese fähigkeit für ein sauberes
energiesystem genutzt werden
doch die fachleute stehen noch ganz am
anfang dazu alfred spormann von der
stanford university in kalifornien von
den elektro artmann wissen wir erst seit
etwa einem jahrzehnt die elektronen
fresser sind sogar erst seit wenigen
jahren bekannt
mittlerweile weiß man dass alle elektro
mikroben die bislang bekannt sind aus
der frühzeit der erde stammen damals
existierte in der erdatmosphäre noch
kein sauerstoff der aber eine äußerst
wichtige funktion als elektronen
abnehmer spielt und so waren die ersten
lebewesen dazu gezwungen sich etwas
anderes einfallen zu lassen nehmen wir
das beispiel des bakteriums namens
schneller
denn sis dass auch heutzutage in seinem
lebensraum am meeresboden ungünstige
zeiten komplett ohne sauerstoff über
wollten muss seine energetisch
ausgebeuteten elektronen gibt es dann an
eisenreiche sedimente seiner umgebung ab
konkret funktioniert das über leitende
membran fortsetze
forschungsteams ist es tatsächlich
gelungen daraus eine quelle für
elektrizität zu basteln dafür wird das
bakterium an die anode eines
stromkreises gelockt und zwar mit einer
appetitlichen portion ladung dort wird
es dann mit organischem material
gefüttert und schon sorgt der einzeller
dafür dass strom fließt
anwendungsmöglichkeiten dafür gibt es
zuhauf batterien die auf der basis von
bakterien funktionieren oder aber
lösungen in denen die mikroorganismen
aus menschlichen abwässern strom
gewinnen sollen in china arbeiten
forschungsdienst derzeit daran die
bakterien gentechnisch dahin zu bringen
dass sie zwei verschiedene sorten von
elektronen tunnel nebeneinander tragen
und so ihre elektrische ausbeute
steigern
doch die sogenannten micro bayern fuel
cells sind noch nicht wirklich effektiv
bis jetzt doch die idee funktioniert und
zwar mit milchsäure im labor der test in
der kläranlage steht bisher noch aus
doch das ist nicht der einzige weg diese
elektro mikroben zu nutzen denn manche
von ihnen bedienen auch die andere
richtung sie sind in der lage strom in
wertvolle rohstoffe umzuwandeln
die bakterien namens metallo cocos marie
paradies beispielsweise leben tief am
boden
dort leben sie nicht nur von wasserstoff
und kohlendioxid sondern können wohl
tatsächlich elektronen aufnehmen um
daraus selbst wasserstoff zu produzieren
das ganze funktioniert wohl mit einem
noch unbekannten proteinkomplex den man
sich wie
eine art trinkt heim für elektronen
vorstellen kann der dadurch auf
gesunkene strom wird in kombination mit
co2 genutzt um dann methan also erdgas
herzustellen eine super spannende sache
also nicht nur für energieunternehmen
von denen schon viele interesse an
diesem konzept bekundet haben
und das natürlich nicht ohne grund und
tatsächlich könnten diese bakterien das
zentrale problem der energiewende lösen
denn windräder und so weiter und so fort
sammeln viel mehr strom als sie in den
netze geben können so dass millionen
euro verloren gehen
zudem werden die netze durch diese
schwankungen in der stromerzeugung
geschwächt gesucht wird deswegen
händeringend nach einer wirtschaftlichen
möglichkeit der stromspeicherung dazu
spormann diese bakterien tun genau das
und zwar ohne den energieverlust den man
beim betreiben von biogasanlagen oder
die elektrochemische wasserstoff
synthese für ähnliche systeme hinnehmen
muss wo das ist alles wirklich ein
riesenschritt also egal jetzt welches
verfahren denn damit können wir zum
beispiel anders als mit dem üblichen
steinzeitlichen verfahren strom erzeugen
denn damit können wir aus rohstoffen als
energiequelle ohne das übliche verfahren
wir verbrennen den rohstoff und mit der
werbe treiben wir dann mit erheblichen
verlusten einen generator an mit diesem
prinzip sind wir immer noch nicht über
die dampfmaschine heraus etwa
atomkraftwerken bono also diese technik
könnte da einen riesen fortschritt
bedeuten wenn es dort weitere
entwicklungen gibt der vater ist
natürlich hier und weitere solchen
bahnbrechenden themen gibt es nicht nur
bei uns sondern auch bei technology
review und tahir wenn er darauf klickt
bekommt er ein gratis exemplar also auf
jeden fall machen und darunter geht es
auf unserem englischen kanal weiter mit
competition tue ihnen mass flying cranes
von china also cios und stay tuned